bar Spinosa was a 17th century Dutch
philosopher who tried to reinvent
religion moving it away from something
based on Superstition and ideas of
direct divine intervention to being a
discipline that was going to be far more
impersonal quasi scientific and yet also
at times serenely
consoling bah the word means blessed in
Hebrew was Bor born in the Jewish
quarter of Amsterdam in 1632 a thriving
Center of Jewish Commerce and thought
his ancestors were sphardic Jews who had
fled the Spanish Peninsula following the
Catholic inspired expulsion of
1492 bar a studious highly intelligent
child received an intensely traditional
Jewish Education he went to the local
Jewish school the Yeshiva and followed
all the Jewish High holidays and rituals
but gradually he began to distance
himself from the faith of his ancestors
although I have been educated from
Boyhood in the accepted beliefs
concerning scripture he later wrote with
characteristic caution I have felt Bound
in the end to embrace other views his
fully fleshed out views were to be
expressed in his great work the ethics
written entirely in Latin and published
in 1677 in the ethics Spinosa directly
challenged the main tenants of Judaism
in particular and organized religion in
general God is not a person who stands
outside of nature there is no one to
hear our prayers or to create Miracles
or to punish ious for misdeeds there is
no afterlife man is not God's chosen
creature the Bible was only written by
Ordinary People God is not a Craftsman
or an architect nor is he a king or a
military strategist who calls for
believers to take up the holy sword God
doesn't see anything nor does he expect
anything he doesn't judge he doesn't
even reward The Virtuous with a life
after death every representation of God
as a person is a projection of the
imagination and everything in the
traditional lurgical calendar is pure
Superstition and mumbo jumbo however
despite all this remarkably Spinosa did
not declare himself an atheist he
insisted that he remained a staunched
offender of God God plays an absolutely
Central role in Spinoza's ethics but it
isn't anything like The God Who haunts
the pages of the Old Testament Spinoza's
God is Holy impersonal and
indistinguishable from what we might
variously call nature or existence or a
World's Soul God is the universe and its
laws God is reason and Truth God is the
animating force in everything that is
and can be he is not in time and he
cannot be individuated Spinosa writes
whatever is is in God and nothing can
exist or be conceived without God
throughout his text Spinosa was Keen to
undermine the idea of Prayer in prayer
an individual appeals to God to change
the way the universe works but Spinosa
argues that this is entirely the wrong
way around the task of human beings is
to try to understand how and why the
universe works the way it does and then
accept it rather than protest at the
workings of existence by sending little
messages up into the sky as Spinosa put
it beautifully but rather caustically
whosoever loves God cannot strive that
God should love him in return in other
words only a deeply distorted and
infantile narcissism would lead someone
at once to believe in God and then to
imagine that this God would take an
interest in bending the rules of
existence to improve his or her life in
some way
Spinosa was deeply influenced by the
philosophy of the stoics of ancient
Greece and Rome they had argued that
wisdom lies not in protest against how
things are but in continuous attempts to
understand the ways of the world and
then bow down peacefully to necessity
senica Spinoza's favorite philosopher
had compared human beings to dogs on a
leash being led by the necessities of
life in a range of directions the more
one pulls against what's necessary the
more one is strangled and therefore the
wise must always Endeavor to try to
understand ahead of time how things are
for example what love is like or how
politics works and then change their
Direction accordingly so as not to be
strangled unnecessarily it is this kind
of stoic attitude that constantly
pervades Spinoza's philosophy to
understand God traditionally means
studying the Bible and another holy text
but Spinosa now introduces another idea
the best way to know God is to
understand how life and the universe
work it's through through a knowledge of
psychology philosophy and the Natural
Sciences that one comes to understand
God In traditional religion Believers
ask special favors of God Spinosa
proposes instead that we should
understand what God wants and we can do
so in one way above all by studying
everything that is by reasoning we can
exceed to a Divine Eternal perspective
Spinosa made a famous distinction
between two ways of looking at life we
can either see it egoistically from our
limited point of view as he put
subey duris under the aspect of time or
we can look at things globally and
eternally subey eternit tartis under the
aspect of Eternity our nature means that
we'll always be divided between the two
sensual life pulls us towards a Time
bound partial view but our reason and
intelligence can give us unique access
to another perspective it can quite
literally allow us and here Spinosa
becomes beautifully lyrical to
participate in Eternal totality normally
we call bad whatever is bad for us and
good whatever increases our power and
Advantage but for Spinosa to be truly
ethical means Rising above such local
concerns it might all sound forbidding
but Spinosa envisaged his philosophy as
a root to a life based on freedom from
guilt from sorrow from pity or from
shame happiness involves aligning our
will with that of the universe the
universe God has its own projects and
it's our task to understand rather than
rail against these the free person is
one conscious of the Necessities that
compel us all Spinosa writes the wise
man the person who understands how and
why things are possesses eternally true
complacency of spirit needless to say
these ideas got Spinosa into very deep
trouble he was excommunicated from the
Jewish community of Amsterdam in 1656
the rabbis issued a writ known as a
sherem against the philosopher it went
by the decree of the angels and by the
command of the holy men we excommunicate
expel curse and Dam bah Espinosa with
all the curses which are written in the
book of law cursed be he by day and
cursed be he By Night cursed be he when
he lies down and cursed be he when he
rises up Spinosa was forced to flee
Amsterdam and eventually settled in the
hag where he lived quietly and
peacefully as a lens grinder and private
tutor till his death in 1677 Spinoza's
work was largely forgotten down the ages
Hegel took an interest as did viken
Stein and several other 20th century
philosophers but from many perspectives
Spinoza's work constitutes a warning
about the failures of philosophy the
ethics is one of the world's most
beautiful books it contains a calming
perspective restoring take on life it
replaces the god of superstition with a
wise and consoling pantheism and yet
Spinoza's work failed utterly to
convince any but a few to abandon
traditional religion and to move towards
a rationalist why system of belief the
reasons are in a way simple and Bal
Spinosa failed to understand like so
many philosophers before and since that
what leads people to religion isn't just
reason but far more importantly emotion
belief fear and tradition people stick
with their beliefs because they like the
ritual the communal meals the yearly
Traditions the beautiful architecture
the music and the lovely language read
out in synagogue or church Spinoza's
ethics arguably contains a whole lot
more wisdom than the Bible but because
it comes without any of the Bible
supporting structure it remains a
marginal work studied here and there at
universities in the west while the
traditional religion that Spinosa
thought out moded in the 1670s continues
to thrive and convince people if we're
ever to replace traditional beliefs we
must remember just how much religion is
helped Along by ritual tradition art and
a desire to belong all things that
Spinosa despite his great wisdom ignored
it his Peril in his bold attempt to
replace the Bible